son frère servier
n'a pas vu son n'a pas vu son frère
sortir c'est poser des questions il est
descendu voir dans le pavillon il a
trouvé son frère allongé à côté du lit
en arrêt cardiaque
en arrêt cardiaque alors on sait quelles
sont les causes de son décès parce que
il a vu donc on l'a vu à son accident on
l'avait vu ici il était vraiment tuméfié
il avait vraiment il avait eu beaucoup
beaucoup de séquelles de cet accident
vous ils font mal et dit qu'il prenait
des médicaments voilà pour calmer la
douleur ce qu'il aime encore extrêmement
mal suite à ce qui s'était passé
exactement elle arrivait pas il
n'arrivait pas à dormir normes et très
peu on le voyait nous tous les jours
s'affaiblir il avait toujours le sourire
montré aucun hills et j'ai un peu mal
mais ça va ça va mais n'arrivait pas à
dormir donc il a été voir son médecin
traitant qui lui a acculé a prescrit des
médicaments pour pouvoir dormir et on
suppose que à cause de ces médicaments
là il a il l'a fait cet arrêt cardiaque
il n'a jamais eu de problèmes de coeur
comment il allait depuis son agression
il s'en remet tait et le moral aller
mieux ou alors les missions de la fait
énormément de bien c'est à dire qu'à
l'extérieur les gens là étaient était
très gentil avec lui donc c'est lui a
fait vraiment du bien il avait le
sourire tous les jours il y avait un
dentiste très gentil à dr berda que je
remercie qui lui avait proposé de
refaire ses dents ils étaient pressés
d'avoir sa nouvelle dentition
qui leur a pas et
et voilà il était à il était comme il
est d'habitude souriant joyeux ali c'est
quelqu'un il a réussi à s'en remettront
pas du tout c'est au centime comme je
vous ai dit des premiers jours il était
déjà passé à autre chose qu'il gênait
c'est vraiment sa douleur au bras
et il ne parlait pas de la cause il
disait j'ai mal c'est tout et je
je veux que ça s'arrête je veux que ça
s'arrête mais il il revenait pas sur
sur la cause du du mal alors ils nous
avaient dit que la police lui avaient
conseillé de ne plus se rendre dans le
café pour éviter les représailles et ce
qui y retourner ou y retourner partout
où il allait j'ai appris par par maître
queux il avait quand même cette crainte
qui nous a dit qu'il ne l'a jamais dit
nous a jamais dit qu'il avait peur d'y
aller mais il y aller il ya les à noisy
tout le monde aime donc tout le monde
parle avec lui
c'est quelqu'un de très gentil donc ils
avaient le sourire
il était heureux de vivre
alice est quelqu'un vous ai dit il a vu
son bac à saison il parle couramment
l'anglais il
ok c'était quoi votre sentiment aussi
quand vous avez appris la la disparition
de votre comme tout le monde la colère
je pense qu'il ya deux solutions soit on
fait comme les enfants et on réagit avec
l' envie de j'ai envie de leur faire du
mal j'ai envie de me venger j'ai envie
de et puis après on se dit qu'on est des
adultes qu on a aussi des gens vous
dites aujourd'hui trois 3 jours après on
n'est pas dans la vengeance ben ali ne
voulais pas être dans la vengeance ali
on se dit que on est croyants et que si
les partis s'il devait partir
maintenant on faire pleurer notre
famille pour remplacer notre famille qui
pleure
c'est parce qu'on veut ce parce qu'on
veut moi je veux rendre hommage à ali
ali il arrivait à quatre ans de
d'algérie il a toujours grandi en
pavillon il n'a jamais connu un hlm j'ai
entendu qu'il avait été sdf et l'aja
mairie jamais on l'appelait le napoléon
à l'école il a eu son bac à 16 ans
surtout à l'époque c'était c'était un
exploit n'avait sauté des classes zidi
parlez couramment l'anglais et il a
voyagé ensuite il a une déficience
mentale
mais voilà personne ne peut dire dans
noisy il n'a jamais été connu des
services de police il a jamais eu une
amende il sait que leur gain de 2,2 il
est très gentil et je tiens à lui rendre
hommage